é
étaient coincés dans les ports
ukrainiens depuis e la Russie.
Et on évoquait déjà une possible
crise alimentaire mondiale.
Mais après des mois de
négociations, un abul relâche ln
sur le marché mondial
des grains.
L'Ukrain12 % du blé
exporté dans le monde.
Toute sa dernière récolte, soit
est entreposée en attente
ouverture des
dangereuses routes maritimes
de la mer Noire, contrôlées
L'accord, très attendu,
sera d'une durée de quatre mois.
En contrepartie, les Russes
leurs propres récoltes de blé
ne feronjetjetjetjetjetjet
de sanctions internationales.
Pour les experts, l'accord
si la solution est temporaire.
SÉBASTIEN POULIOT, économiste,
- C'est important en ce moment
de sortir le grain de l'Ukra
parce que la récolte,
la nouvelle récolte, ça commence
Donc, les capacités
d'entreposage sont
en Ukraine.
- Malgré cette entente,
quant à la bonne foi des Russes.
Tout coma.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
la Russie. J'ai pas confiance
en Vladimir Poutine.
- Selon le fédéral,
la surveillance étroite
en mer Noire est une nécessité.r
que tous les moyens qu'on a
pour sortir ces grains sansine
soient au coeur detoutes nos di.
(explosion)
t ce temps,
la guerre se poursuit et
plusieurs récoltes continu
de l'Ukraine.
"Les fermiers font ce qu'ils
les récoltes sont fragiles et
ils doivent parfois travaill
au risque de leur vie."
Ici Normand Grond